Here are 3 lines of things that the computer has done for me.
The very first one you should just ignore. It'll always be there. Just ignore it.
It tells the computer that we wish to plot things.
The second and the third one were the important ones.
I define a data set--a data set is a list of 10 elements--3, 4, 2, 4, 3, 5, 3, 6, 4, 3 that I made up
and with this line, I tell the computer that this over here is my data.
Then I tell the computer, "Please histogram plot my data"--and then this is the result I just shown you.
Here are the 3 things that we have to tell the computer.
If you ignore the cryptic "from plotting import *," then what we do is we define the data.
We list it, we give it a name called data, and we generate a histogram plot of the data.
Then we then hit run in the small box down here--you'll get exactly the plot that I've shown you
where the frequency of the data is plotted accordingly.
Obviously, that range was 2.8 with 3.6 as the most frequent and if we go back up to the data.
We find yet 3 occurrences of 3 with 4 into this range. This is the most frequent range.